you've got the random sample get the
random sample just give you a real
number pick some numbers randomly what
if this s add on to random sample its
stratified which is what's this like
stratified idea yeah it's about
proportions of like I've got this many
sevens and this many red so I'm gonna
get I want to get the proportions right
what was this last one was the strange
little dramatic systematic sample and
everyone goes crazy crazy um why would
we make it systematic is that the
opposite of random don't you want to be
ready to what why don't you wanna marry
me you what is it why does they don't
remember the example I gave you before
there's a particular place actually a
couple of different places
that's right so if you were checking
something and this kind of like these
people are gonna go past you and you're
never gonna get them back or it's very
hard to get everyone into one spot and
randomly check everyone then a
systematic sample will make sure at
regular intervals you get something so
today what we're going to focus on is
picking which ones of which now the
image I want to leave you with as you're
doing this is this picture these
different kinds of samples they are
different kinds of tools for very
similar kinds of problems okay so what
do we got here Kenneth can you guys see
the pictures what are we got you got a
hammer a nail
you've got a is anyone know what it's
called actually it is okay so this is
particular this is a spanner you'd
usually use a wrench for this that's the
adjustable one and uh what's it called
a bowl thank you much okay um easy one
screwdriver and all of the IKEA people
are like Alan King
okay now each of these is solving the
same kind of problem right it's like
look I've got things that need to be
attached or fastened and so you can see
like the shapes of these things are very
similar to each other but they're all
divides kind of a different angle or a
slightly different mechanism based on
like what materials are you touching
together
well what tools do you have available to
you and what kinds of things are easy to
give to the people who are going to be
constructing these tables and chairs and
it's exactly the same with these right
you choose the tool based on what kind
of signal radio you're in you know I'm
all about metaphors now one last item
before I get you going on these
questions is it you'll have a look at
some I'll just I'll show you what I mean
you're gonna have a look at some
scenarios right you go these scenarios
and you're going to be us well okay
which of these is the most suitable then
why okay now just like the tools I
showed you before if I give you a
surface I don't think it's necessarily
depending on the situation in looking at
immediately obvious or clear-cut which
one of these you could use in a given
situation it's like you know what nails
or screws they would both be fine so
long as you justify why you're using one
or the other right and it's exactly the
same where you come back to this um
therefore many of these it's like we
know what a couple of these would
probably work right but the important
thing is can you tell me why can you
discuss give me a reason right you want
to go for a systematic sample that's
fine you could have done random as well
but if you know why you chose this one
the other one that's the part that's
being assessed does that make sense